Caption: hello hello how's everyone doing did you
Caption: enjoy the morning tea alright ready to
Caption: listen about reactive programming and
Caption: rxjs alright so thanks for our sponsors
Caption: I'm Chris filippov ski I'm a software
Caption: engineer and I work in a medium-sized
Caption: mining company in Perth called index
Caption: previously I worked in Nokia and I'm
Caption: mostly JavaScript and type developer
Caption: doing some backend work in node.js and
Caption: quite a bit of front-end and I'm here
Caption: today to give you a gentle I hope
Caption: introduction to reactive programming and
Caption: because I remember when I heard about
Caption: rxjs it was about three years ago and I
Caption: wanted to learn reactive programming and
Caption: I started googling and I landed on the
Caption: documentation page and I started to read
Caption: about all the operators that were over
Caption: there and I felt pretty confused and I
Caption: think I felt pretty similar to this guy
Caption: who posted this question on Stack
Caption: Overflow so I'm trying to learn react
Caption: effects
Caption: I have spent almost a whole day and I'm
Caption: not able to understand it properly I try
Caption: to look at the official documentation
Caption: but it's very difficult to understand
Caption: something like this Eric's observable
Caption: prototype flatmap latest projects each
Caption: element of an observable sequence into a
Caption: new sequence of observable sequences by
Caption: incorporate incorporating the elements
Caption: index and then transforms an observable
Caption: sequence of observable sequences into an
Caption: observable sequence producing values
Caption: only from the most recent observable
Caption: sequence and I already knew at that
Caption: moment that I'm not able to understand
Caption: our edges just by looking at the
Caption: documentation and hopefully there are
Caption: better ways to learn that but what it
Caption: really is this reactive programming so
Caption: at the beginning I would like to show
Caption: you an example of application that works
Caption: in a highly reactive manner that you've
Caption: might seen before and that's the next
Caption: spreadsheet here we have like three
Caption: input fields and the fourth one is a
Caption: concatenation of the previous these
Caption: three others and ones which
Caption: one of these fields the change of the
Caption: input field is propagated to the output
Caption: field immediately once I change here the
Caption: change is propagated immediately to the
Caption: output stream without any refresh or
Caption: update and that's basically what the
Caption: reactive programming is in its core
Caption: putting it in towards reactive
Caption: programming is programming with
Caption: asynchronous data streams and a stream
Caption: is a sequence of ongoing events ordered
Caption: in time in our Excel example this
Caption: sequence of events were just values that
Caption: we were inserting inputting into the
Caption: cells in Excel so I would like you to
Caption: think of an stream as an array which is
Caption: ordered in time so if that would be an
Caption: array of five values that would be the
Caption: stream of five values ordered in time
Caption: and on top of that concept we have a
Caption: reactive extension which is an amazing
Caption: tool box for creating combining and
Caption: filtering those streams in very
Caption: declarative and immutable way in a
Caption: similar manner as we do it currently on
Caption: JavaScript our eyes that we have
Caption: functions like map filter reduce as you
Caption: might be familiar with and reactive
Caption: extension is available for many
Caption: languages there is a check yes there is
Caption: like 18 of them it's like Eric's Java
Caption: or.net or XP HP Python the Ruby Swift
Caption: caught in a lot of languages so once you
Caption: learn it once departing you'll be able
Caption: to apply it in whatever language that
Caption: you'll be using
Caption: especially reactive Jes is not a
Caption: framework specific so you can use it
Caption: with vanilla JavaScript it works really
Caption: well with react view is the first class
Caption: citizen in angular apps and there is
Caption: also a psychologist framework that is
Caption: built upon the concept of it so there's
Caption: a lot of things that you can use it with
Caption: so you might be wondering what kind of
Caption: streams you might have in your
Caption: applications and some people says that
Caption: everything can be a stream but
Caption: in most situations our streams are
Caption: composed I composed out of HTTP requests
Caption: user interactions like mouse movements
Caption: keyboard events animations handling
Caption: multiple WebSocket connections route
Caption: changes state changes and and so on so
Caption: how does it work so reactive extension
Caption: is build upon the concept of observable
Caption: and observer and we can think of
Caption: observable of something that produces
Caption: data and observer as something that
Caption: lists that data and the intention of
Caption: listening to the data is expressed by
Caption: the keyword subscribe after we subscribe
Caption: to observable observer observable starts
Caption: to produce data an observer can receive
Caption: this data if we put it into the code we
Caption: can see that observable is nothing more
Caption: than an object that implements a metal
Caption: subscribe and an observer is just a
Caption: bundle of free callbacks on next on
Caption: error and uncomplete and if you've been
Caption: programming in JavaScript you you might
Caption: think now that it's pretty similar to
Caption: the concept that prior to before or used
Caption: before this is pretty similar to
Caption: promises some people call it observables
Caption: as promises class class or promises on
Caption: steroids and that's true
Caption: because when you look at how we trigger
Caption: the promise we are using the keyword
Caption: then then we are passing a callback
Caption: function success in observable we are
Caption: having subscribe and instead of success
Caption: function we are passing in next function
Caption: the difference is because promise can
Caption: resolve only ones but observable can
Caption: resolve multiple times over and over
Caption: again then the second callback is an
Caption: error function is the same as in
Caption: promises and just because observable can
Caption: emit multiple times we need to have a
Caption: callback that suggests that okay this
Caption: stream has completed and will not emit
Caption: any values in the future and on top of
Caption: that there is it is also cancelable
Caption: which is advantage over the using
Caption: promises as well
Caption: and of course we have the whole bunch of
Caption: operators that we can use it with if you
Caption: would like to look how we can represent
Caption: it visually it's often in the
Caption: documentation is represented in a marble
Caption: diagrams which look like the the line of
Caption: time in a silver balls we have emitted
Caption: values the X represents the error event
Caption: and vertical line the completed signal
Caption: there's also an ASCII diagram that might
Caption: be very useful if you want to comment
Caption: your code or there are even libraries
Caption: that helps you unit test your streams
Caption: using just these ASCII diagrams so you
Caption: put it as an input enough what you're
Caption: expecting so let's look at some
Caption: imperative code that we might have
Caption: written so here we have a variable a
Caption: assign five variable B and variable C is
Caption: just a product of a and B so in line for
Caption: the value of C will be ten that what
Caption: would happen in later in time one of
Caption: this a and B would change for example B
Caption: would change to three and we would like
Caption: to check what's the value of C and it
Caption: would be still 10 and in some situations
Caption: we would expect it to be updated to the
Caption: current values like 15 and to have such
Caption: behavior in imperative code we'd have to
Caption: run this operation a multiply by B again
Caption: and how we can refactor it into reactive
Caption: way so let's try it now on so first what
Caption: we want to do instead of having variable
Caption: a equals 5 you want to have a to be a
Caption: stream of that M its value a so in order
Caption: to do that we'll import the operator of
Caption: that creates an stream of a single value
Caption: we'll rename the variable name to $1
Caption: which is a standard convention name for
Caption: observables in
Caption: rxjs will do the same with with swingby
Caption: and our stream C needs to be a
Caption: combination of the latest emitted value
Caption: of the stream a and V and in order to do
Caption: that we have our having an operator
Caption: combine lattice that does exactly what I
Caption: mentioned so this so far we'll take the
Caption: latest value of a and B and we can pass
Caption: a function that will take the latest
Caption: values of a and B and we'll just
Caption: multiply it remove that one if we run
Caption: this code nothing could happen yet we
Caption: need to subscribe to our observable fair
Caption: so we'll subscribe to our stream C and
Caption: just for a simplicity we'll just
Caption: console.log this value and let's see
Caption: what happens so when you run this code
Caption: we have the output over here equals 10
Caption: but what would happen if one of these
Caption: values will change later in time to for
Caption: example 3 later in time would have value
Caption: 15 so if you put that into into a little
Caption: bit of HTML and we'll connect the stream
Caption: 8 when one input and stream B to the
Caption: other input wherever will change the
Caption: value here the output will be changing
Caption: so that's pretty much it so that was the
Caption: code before like in a variety way that's
Caption: how it looks in reactive way so what
Caption: we've done in a marble diagrams it would
Caption: look like this we have a stream a that
Caption: emitted value 5 and once this both of
Caption: the streams emitted at least one value
Caption: we have value emitted in the output
Caption: stream which is 10 and 1 every time when
Caption: the stream a or b emits value we have
Caption: value emitted on the output stream as
Caption: well
Caption: quite important thing to know up front
Caption: that there is a difference between hot
Caption: and cold observables maybe not when you
Caption: start but later on when you will start
Caption: subscribing multiple times to an
Caption: observables you will see the difference
Caption: so the difference is that when you have
Caption: a cold observable if you subscribe to it
Caption: multiple times you will always get the
Caption: same stream of data and it's 100%
Caption: predictable examples of it is like
Caption: observable created of a single value of
Caption: an RI of an interval of an AJAX request
Caption: so wherever we subscribe to an AJAX
Caption: request every time we'll make another
Caption: HTTP call on the other hand we have hot
Caption: observables that are actually producing
Caption: data before we've subscribed to it and
Caption: once we subscribe to the observable we
Caption: are gonna be getting only the data from
Caption: the moment of subscriptions and this
Caption: examples of circles are for example
Caption: mouse movements and once we subscribe to
Caption: the event rate to the stream that is
Caption: created out of the mouse movement even
Caption: we'll be getting only positions from the
Caption: current moment of subscriptions and we
Caption: want to get the whole history of events
Caption: where the mouse was before it's
Caption: sometimes good to know that we can warm
Caption: up our cold observables by using sharp
Caption: but I want go into details with that so
Caption: far let's look at some operators that
Caption: gives a real power for like of this
Caption: reactive programming party so the first
Caption: one if you're using javascript is
Caption: operate your map might be very similar
Caption: we are having a transformation function
Caption: in our case it's just a square function
Caption: once we get a value on the input string
Caption: immediately we will get the square of
Caption: this value in the output stream another
Caption: operator that is quite familiar to
Caption: JavaScript developers is familiy filter
Caption: another one in JavaScript developers of
Caption: course but yeah there's filter that we
Caption: have a predicate function so in here
Caption: will be only allowing values that are
Caption: bigger than 10 to pass through our
Caption: filter that's I hope it's pretty much
Caption: clear
Caption: and we are having a little bit different
Caption: operators on our ice that on streams
Caption: that are not usually on our ice and for
Caption: example there is an operator skip while
Caption: that will be it works a little bit like
Caption: filter but it skips until the condition
Caption: that we give will be false so in this
Caption: example we skipping all the values until
Caption: the X will be 22 and from that time on
Caption: it will be passing all the data flow so
Caption: you're waiting until X will be 22 and
Caption: then we are passing through and that
Caption: might be useful when we for example wait
Caption: for some variables to initialize in our
Caption: stream quite interesting is the bounce
Caption: time and if you've ever implemented
Caption: type-ahead or autocomplete in your code
Caption: it probably came across the bounds and
Caption: you've implemented in one way or the
Caption: other but with reactive extension is
Caption: just one line of code and let's imagine
Caption: that we have here a search we type one
Caption: letter and stop what the bounce does
Caption: just wait a period given here of the
Caption: time like 300 milliseconds and if there
Caption: is no other event it propagates it to
Caption: the output stream but what happens if we
Caption: type more letters at once
Caption: it won't emit every single value it will
Caption: just wait just is 300 milliseconds after
Caption: the last immediate value and just
Caption: propagated to the output stream so this
Caption: is very good way to limit number of
Caption: requests that we are doing to our server
Caption: so let's look a little bit of the
Caption: examples so here we have an example of
Caption: like more full-blown type-ahead
Caption: so what we are doing here is we are
Caption: creating an observable from event key up
Caption: on a target in our case target could be
Caption: an input HTML input then we are piping
Caption: it through operator map in order to from
Caption: event to get just the value the string
Caption: value then we are piping it through the
Caption: bounce time then we are using this thing
Caption: until change
Caption: which actually works similar to filter
Caption: but it filters out the value that are
Caption: the same as the previous emission so
Caption: we'll have only the values that changed
Caption: so if someone for example types a letter
Caption: and remove that letter quickly it we
Caption: won't get that even propagated and then
Caption: we are using a switch map operator
Caption: that's actually switching from one
Caption: observable to the other in our case it's
Caption: a search observable that's actually an
Caption: ajax request to the database and this
Caption: particular search observable is piped
Caption: fro retry operator which is quite
Caption: powerful because it can retry given
Caption: number of times if it fails because of
Caption: some reason so this piece of code is
Caption: quite terse I think and there's quite a
Caption: lot of things and it's I think once you
Caption: get it it's quite easy to understand as
Caption: well some people says that you can
Caption: implement redux in just one line of code
Caption: I'll refer to this link below but basic
Caption: idea of course I'm not recommending to
Caption: use it like just for a placement of
Caption: Redux because there you don't have like
Caption: all the goodness of relax like developer
Caption: tools and etc but the basic concept can
Caption: be implemented just with rxjs and we can
Caption: have a observable store that will be
Caption: created out of our actions and it will
Caption: start with initial state and operator
Caption: scan works in a similar way that it
Caption: accumulates the latest value that's
Caption: produced out of the reducer function
Caption: that is the same as in redux that it
Caption: takes the previous state and the action
Caption: in the creates mutable new state and I
Caption: won't be getting into details with other
Caption: examples we can talk after the talk if
Caption: you want one less thing to to mention if
Caption: you don't want to find yourself looking
Caption: for memory leaks in your applications
Caption: don't forget to answer
Caption: scribe because otherwise it will like
Caption: our memory footprint will be growing and
Caption: we can do it in two ways once imperative
Caption: just by calling and subscribe or we can
Caption: use more reactive way by using one of
Caption: operators like take take while or take
Caption: until which will actually for example we
Caption: can X explicitly say that take for
Caption: example five Emmys and after taking five
Caption: Emmys it will be the stream will be just
Caption: completed or if you are using a new
Caption: angular you can use an icing pipe and
Caption: angular will take care of unsubscribing
Caption: when your view is destroyed and as my
Caption: personal final thoughts as I would like
Caption: to say if you haven't been playing with
Caption: reactive programming just in if you if
Caption: you will find yourself on a
Caption: documentation page and reading about
Caption: like 120 operators which might be quite
Caption: confusing just forget about them for now
Caption: I don't know personally all of them
Caption: start using them as use promises
Caption: currently and maybe get your feet wet
Caption: with just one or two simple operators
Caption: like map or filter and then once you
Caption: need it you can improve and as Ben Lesh
Caption: the current mental maintainer of our HJs
Caption: says you don't have to rx all the things
Caption: just do as much as you can in a reactive
Caption: way and do the rest imperatively and
Caption: that's totally fine
Caption: and yeah that's all I have prepared for
Caption: today here are some materials that you
Caption: can have a look at here's a simplified
Caption: documentation this guide on choosing
Caption: operators that you can have an
Caption: interactive questionnaire what you want
Caption: to do like what kind of operator you
Caption: want a little bit of fun with
Caption: implementing snake in rxjs and yeah
Caption: that's pretty much it thank you
Caption: you